>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
NOT A LOT OF AMERICANS PAY
ATTENTION TO EUROPEAN POLITICS.
THAT'S UNDERSTANDABLE.
IT'S A SHAME.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN EUROPE YOU CAN MORE THAN
ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
DESPITE THE CASTLES AND FUNNY
ACCENT AND SMELLY CHEESE, EUROPE
IS NOT THAT DIFFERENT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
EUROPEAN LEADERS RUN THEIR
COUNTRIES THE SAME WAY OUR
LEADERS RUN OUR COUNTRY.
THEY GO ON ENDLESSLY ABOUT
DEMOCRACY BUT DO THEIR BEST TO
IT AVOID DEMOCRACY'S MOST BASK
REQUIREMENTS LIKE FREE SPEECH
AND REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT.
THE PRIME MINISTER OF ITALY
A FEW YEARS AGO BRAGGED TO THE
WORLD ECONOMIC FORUM ABOUT HIS
PLANS TO BRING MORE SOCIAL
JUSTICE TO THE COUNTRY MEANING
HE WOULD IMPORT MORE MIGRANTS
FROM THE THIRD WORLD INTO
EUROPE.
WE ARE SAVING LIVES AT SEA!
OH, SAVING LIVES.
YOU ARE SUCH A GOOD PERSON.
THE QUESTION IS:
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN ITALY
THINK OF THAT IDEA?
-- WHAT?
THE PRIME MINISTER DIDN'T CARE.
QUOTE:
ARE YOU FOLLOWING THIS YOU?
RUN A COUNTRY IN THE NAME OF
PEOPLE.
YOU ARE NOT A KING.
YOU ARE AN ELECTED LEADER.
BUT IT'S DANGEROUS TO IT ALLOW
THE OPINION OF THOSE PEOPLE TO
INFLUENCE YOUR DECISIONS.
DOES THAT FAMILIAR?
THAT'S THE KIND OF DEMOCRACY WE
LIVE IN, A FAKE ONE.
IN FACT THERE IS NO MAJORITY IN
ANY COUNTRY ON THE PLANET EARTH
OF THAT THINKS OPEN BORDERS ARE
A GOOD IDEA OR CONSIDERS GLOBAL
WARMING THE BIGGEST PROBLEM OR
THINK IT'S WISE TO QUARANTINE
THE POPULATION BECAUSE OF A FLU
VIRUS.
NO GROUP OF PEOPLE WANTS THESE
THINGS.
IN THE WEST POLLITITIONS DON'T
CARE WHAT YOU THINK.
SHUT UP RACISTS!
-- THIS CAN'T ENDURE BECAUSE
IT'S UNSTABLE.
YOU CAN'T TELL PEOPLE THEY ARE
IN CHARGE OF THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT AND IGNORE OVER
DECADES THEIR STRONGLY HELD
OPINIONS ON 36 THAT MATTER.
-- ON THINGS THAT MATTER.
THEY WILL REPEL.
YOU HOPE THEY DO IT PEACEFULLY.
IN ITALY THEY ARE DOING THAT.
THIS SUMMER GIORGI MELONI
STARTED SHOWING UP IN THE POLLS.
BECAUSE SHE REFUSED TO BOW TO
THE TWIN GODS OF CLIMATE AND
MIGRATION PEOPLE PANICKED.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION COMMANDED ITALIANS
NOT TO VOTE FOR HER.
WATCH.
>> LET'S SEE IF THINGS GO IN
A DIFFERENT DIRECTION.
I SPOKE WITH HUNGARY AND POLAND.
WE HAVE TOOLS IT IF THINGS GO IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
ALL OF THE GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO
BE ACCOUNTABLE TO PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE.
>> Tucker: IF THINGS GO IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION, IF VOTERS
DISOBEY, WE HAVE TOOLS.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A THREAT
BECAUSE IT IS.
ITALIANS ARE SO DESPERATE, THEY
ARE NOT AFRAID.
BUT LIBERALISM DESTROYED THEIR
COUNTRY.
ENERGY PRICES IN ITALY ARE UP
400% OVER LAST YEAR.
WHY?
A POINTLESS WAR IN UKRAINE AND
SELF-DESTRUCTIVE CLIMATE POLICY.
IT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT.
PARTS OF ITALY ARE DANGEROUS.
WHY?
EVERYONE KNOWS WHY.
IT'S MIGRANTS DRIVING A HUGE
AMOUNT OF THE CRIME.
THESE ARE NOT MYSTERIES, BUT YOU
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEM IN PUBLIC.
MELONI IS ONE OF THE FEW
POLITICIANS THAT IS WILLING TO
STAY THE TRUTH OUT LOUD.
AS A RESULT OF THAT, LAST NIGHT
HER PARTY CALLED BROTHERS OF
ITALY WON AN OVERWHELMING
VICTORY IN ITALY.
THEY TOOK BOTH MAJORITIES IN THE
HOUSES OF PARLIAMENT.
BY AMERICAN STANDARDS THIS IS
A REVOLUTION.
BUT UNLIKE MOST REVOLUTIONS, THE
PERSON AT THE FRONT CAN EXPLAIN
WHAT SHE IS ABOUT IN A WAY
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND.
SHE IS SMART.
THIS IS PART OF THE SPEECH SHE
GAVE EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT LED
TO LAST NIGHT'S RESULTS.
>> OUR FREEDOM IS UNDER ATTACK.
OUR RIGHTS ARE UNDERATTACK.
THE SOVEREIGNTY OF OUR NATION IS
UNDER ATTACK -- THE EDUCATION OF
OUR CHILDREN IS UNDER ATTACK.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IN THIS AGE
THE ONLY WAY OF BEING REBELS IS
TO PRESERVE WHAT WE ARE AND BE
CONSERVATIVE.
THEY WILL TRY TO TAKE EVERYTHING
AWAY FROM US.
BUT THEY CAN'T AWAY WHO WE ARE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
CHERISHING WHO WE ARE, KNOWING
WHAT WE STAND FOR IS ALL WE NEED
TO FACE THIS CHALLENGE.
>> Tucker: SHE IS NOT KIDDING.
SHE IS AS SERIOUS AS THE MOMENT
WE ARE LIVING THROUGH.
OUR RIGHTS ARE UNDER ATTACK AND
THE SOVEREIGNTY OF OUR NATION IS
UNDER ATTACK SHE SAID AND THE
PROSPERITY AND WELL BEING OF OUR
FAMILIES IS UNAUTHORIZED ATTACK.
-- UNDER ATTACK.
THAT'S TRUE HERE.
AMERICAN FAMILIES ARE FACING THE
SAME ONSLAUGHT.
THE DIFFERENCE IS IN THIS
COUNTRY IT'S RARELY ACKNOWLEDGED
EXCEPT ON THE FRINGES.
MELONI IS THE NEW PRIME MINISTER
OF ITALY AND SAYING THAT OUT
LOUD.
IN THE UNITED STATES HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE RUNNING ON THE
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
YOU HAVE NOT READ IT.
NOBODY CARES.
THERE IS NOTHING REAL IN IT.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE WORD IN
THAT DOCUMENT ABOUT THE ATTACKS
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE YOU SEE
EVERY DAY.
HOW ARE MY KIDS?
DOES THE AMERICAN DREAM STILL
EXIST?
WILL THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES
WE HAD?
NO.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY BE, BUT NOBODY
SAYS IT.
THAT'SUD.
-- THAT'S ODD.
WE KNOW WHEN POLITICIANS TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING, THEY TEND TO BE
REWARDED FOR IT.
ONCE AGAIN, HERE'S THE IN COMING
PRIME MINISTER OF ITALY.
ASK YOURSELF IF YOU WOULD VOTE
FOR A CANDIDATE LIKE THIS IF YOU
HAD THE CHANCE IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
DESCRIBED ON AMERICAN TELEVISION
AS FAR RIGHT?
REALLY?
BECAUSE SHE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
AMERICAN FAMILIES ARE UNDER
ATTACK.
IT'S SIMPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO ESTABLISH CONTROL
OVER A COUNTRY, OF COURSE YOU
HAVE TO DESTROY THE FAMILY
FIRST.
BECAUSE NOBODY WITH DEEP FAMILY
LOYALTY WILL EVER PLEDGE
ABSOLUTE OBEDIANCE TO
A POLITICIAN.
IF YOU WANT SALUTES OBEDIENCE
YOU HAVE TO SEVER FAMILY TIES.
SO SCHOOLS BRAIN WASH YOUR
CHILDREN AND INSTRUCT THEM TO
TURN YOU IN IF YOU NOT.
-- BETHE.
OBJECT.
THAT'S HAPPENING.
WOKENESS IS NOT JUST ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
IT'S A STATE RELIGION THAT
SUPPLANTS ACTUAL RELIGION WHICH
IS ALSO BEING DESTROYED.
THERE IS A REASON THE STRIP BARS
AND THE LIQUID STORES STAYED
OPEN UNDER COVID BUT THE
CHURCHES DID NOT.
IF YOU DON'T CONNECT THOSE DOTS
YOU MISS IT.
MELONI UNDERSTANDS IT WATCH.
>> BUREAUCRATS BROUGHT A COUPLE
HUNDREDS OF PAGES LONG TELLING
US IN ORDER TO BE INCLUSIVE, WE
HAVE TO EXCLUDE OFF REFERENCES
TO CHRISTMAS, JESUS, MARY AND
ALL CHRISTIAN NAMES WERE TO BE
ROW MOVED FROM ALL OFFICIAL
COMMUNICATION.
WILL WE SURRENDER IN FRONT OF
THIS?
>> CROWD:
NO.
>> NO, WE WILL FIGHT.
WE WILL FIGHT AND STAND TALL.
>> IT [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Tucker: SO, THEY HATE YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR RELIGION.
DON'T HAVE TO PUT UP WITH IT
BECAUSE IT'S A DEMOCRACY AND YOU
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN CHARGE.
THAT'S A RADICAL MESSAGE, GOD,
FAMILY AND COUNTRY?
THAT'S NOT RADICAL.
FASCISTS DON'T BELIEVE IN
GODBECAUSE GOD IS A RIVAL TO
THEIR POWER.
THAT'S SO SCARY TO THE PEOPLE
RUNNING AND BENEFITING FROM OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM.
WHY IS THAT?
SHE IS NOT THE FIRST PERSON TO
IT SAY THIS.
PEOPLE SAID IT BEFORE, BUT SHE'S
BEEN REWARDED FOR SAYING IT.
THAT'S THE POINT.
THE POPULATION LIKES IT.
THIS IS WHEN THEY WANT.
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
GLOBAL WARMING.
I DEPONENT WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY THINK THE WOKE STUFF IS
ABSURD.
NOW IT'S OBVIOUS BECAUSE SHE
JUST WON.
EVEN IN THIS COUNTRY THE PEOPLE
RUNNING AND BENEFITING FROM
A DEEPLY CORRUPT AND DOOMED
SYSTEM ARE HYSTERICAL.
WATCH THE REACTION TO THAT.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
A POLITICIAN ON THE RIGHT --
A POLITICIAN WHO BRUSHED OFF
ACCUSATIONS OF FASCISM.
>> WHAT SEPARATES US FROM ITALY
WHO ELECTED A FASCIST.
>> THE FAR RIGHT POLITICAL PARTY
WHOSE ROOTS GO BACK TO POST
WORLD WAR II.
>> A PARTY THAT HAS ITS ROOTS IN
FASCISM.
>> Tucker: DEFINE THAT FOR US,
JOE SCARBOROUGH.
YOU CAN'T.
FASCIST IS UNACCEPTABLE.
WHATEVER SHE SAYS YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO AGREE WITH.
THEY ARE WORRIED THAT MANY
ITALIANS AGREE WITH IT.
SHE IS A FASCIST!
A "NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE
MENTIONED FASCIST 29 TIMES.
APPARENTLY ON THE VERGE OF
INVADING POLAND.
WE SHOULD BE WORRIED.
WATCH THIS.
>> THEY SAID IT COULD NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN.
100 YEARS AGO HILLARY CLINTON
AND WORLD WAR II.
THE BROTHERS OF ITALY ONCE ON
THE FRINGES THEY BALLOONED INTO
THE BIGGEST PART IN THE COUNTRY.
NOW THEIR LEADER GIORGI MELONI
WILL HEAD THE MOST HARD RIGHT
GOVERNMENT SINCE THEN.
SHE INSISTS SHE IS NO FASCIST.
JUST A PROUD CONSERVATIVE AND
FASCIST AND COMFORTABLE WITH
THIS FASCIST MOTO.
GOD, FATHERLAND, AND FAMILY.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT'S SCARY!
NOT A WORD ABOUT CLIMATE OR
EQUITY.
IT'S THEIR HYSTERIA AND THEIR
TOTAL UNWILLINGNESS TO ASK
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS THAT LET'S YOU
IN ON THE SECRET.
THEY ARE PANICKED BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
DOOMED.
WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT IN
ITALY IS THE BEST CASE SCENARIO
FOR THEM.
IT WAS A PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF
POWER.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT.
IN A DEMOCRACY PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO HAVE SOME INFLUENCE
ON THE PIRATES OF THE GOVERNMENT
THAT CLAIMS TO REPRESENT THEM.
WHEN THEY SPEAK IN AN ELECTION
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
REPUDIATED HAVE A MOROL -- MORAL
OBLIGATION TO ASK WHY DIDN'T
THEY LIKE WHAT I OFFER?
THEY TAKE NO RESPONSIBILITY.
WHEN TRUMP GOT ELECTED THEY
BLAMED PUTIN.
THEY NEVER LEARNED A SINGLE
THING FROM IS HAPPENING.
THAT'S HAPPENING IN ITALY AND
THE EUROPEAN UNION.
THE BUREAUCRATS WHO DROVE
ITALIANS TO SPEAK A CHANGE AT
THE BALLOT BOX ARE UNWILLING TO
LEARN FROM T